how's it going riley mao is here the
unbustable
doing good yeah yeah yeah how's it going
with the um you know the sexuality and
the
the ejaculate and everything
still the same oh my man
that's what i'm talking about son
i bet people get you to damn come cough
on their plants in the spring just to
keep the uh
just i mean you could be mother nature's
little hit man you could be out there
just blooming things anywhere i bet you
walk across a yard and uh
you know and there's gladiolis under
your feet
the unbustable dude
i
dude
i'll trade you for probably nine cartons
of cigarettes in a uh in san quentin
right now i bet you know yeah i bet
elton
elton john we could sell you for half a
million elton john
you'd be a little christmas ham for him
on his dinner table over there
but how's it been man you've been doing
well
yeah yeah
what's new in your world
uh
nothing much trying to find a girlfriend
oh really yeah and so with being on in
the podcasting universe some are you
getting a lot of dms from ladies what's
going on
mostly from guys
really yeah oh wow and guys looking for
sex
no oh just
friendly men yeah oh that's good yeah
and what but no but not a lot of women
huh no only very few
oh
i feel you there dude damn
i feel you there it's all
it's tough i mean it's you know
one will come along i think
but um
do you so do you ever get that nocturnal
kind of bust you ever wake up in the
morning you just check your pants and
just
look for a prize or anything i mean is
there
are you just still wound up huh yeah man
god i almost wanna
man you gotta live stream it man
you gotta live stream when you
live stream you know what i'm saying
baby you got to really show that off ah
what else you got holiday plans
uh yeah i'm going back to california
oh cool man you guys having a little get
together or what yeah yeah just family
dinner
oh sweet you guys celebrate thanksgiving
we do
oh that's good man
welcome brother
i'm glad you're doing well you look
healthy
temperature good and everything yeah oh
that's good man
that's good so you get pubic hair riley
male you get how's your body doing
overall it's doing good okay
and do you get does it get out of
control or it's manageable for you it's
in a manageable state ah it's pretty
manageable okay that's beautiful dude
could definitely sell you on the market
baby
i get a vpn to hide this browser boy i
get half a million for you somewhere you
know what i'm saying probably sell you
back to your own i'll sell you back to
your own people to be honest with you
praise god brother good to see you today
man
thank you good to see you man and
uh
and god loves us right yeah
that's awesome
always the best answer
um
what are you thankful for
uh
i can tell you i'm not thankful for uh
not having a girlfriend
oh really you really want one huh yeah
at some point yeah
and how is it um
and have you had a lot of dates or
anything have you been doing dating i
just had a coffee date with someone oh
okay
okay didn't end well it didn't end well
well how did it start did you would you
wear
um nice shirt slacks
um
cologne
oh yeah you went there with that scent
huh i did
dude i'm sure you got the pheromones
coming out of your body son
you know i bet you smelled like damn
pure ejac baby
uh
you know what i'm saying about a damn
dude
i bet a [ __ ]
a strong dog would lick the skin right
off your bones baby you know what i'm
saying dog damn
oh god i mean you could cry into a uh
you could cry into a woman and and
and she'd have twins man i think um
and and and where'd y'all go you guys
went to coffee yep okay
and did you
uh
did you meet her out front did you meet
her inside
um
i met her out front oh
okay
uh
and
did you guys get there at the same time
or
i was there first you were there first
waiting out front yep yeah
yeah i think sometimes that can be kind
of
that's a christian move dawg
honestly that's a hell of a christian
move i respect it it's a [ __ ] old
school it's an old school move
um and so then you guys went inside and
what happened
uh we talked it was great
um i shouldn't say it didn't end well it
it ended well um she just never texted
me back and you met her on the apps i
did okay and were you uh
man i'm bummed out what do you think do
you think it
do you really feel here's here's the
question do you really feel there was a
connection or are you not sure i wasn't
sure okay
because sometimes i'll put connection
where there isn't really a connection i
want there to be one sometimes because
i'm lonesome and so i'll be like let's
see and
but sometimes they're re you know there
may not be one but right i'm not saying
that's what happened with you
no it did oh it did happen no oh yeah
and there you go but you're still you're
not giving up no you're still out there
and now can you do
uh
and you're saving your sex for marriage
right yeah that's a marriage meal right
wow
so you got to get all the way to the
altar before you can even get these you
know
get that puree out of you yeah pretty
much god
god baby oh
man
and now what i mean so you could
now what if you're trapped in an
avalanche or something you have to get
would you guys have to just get married
you'd do a sir you figure it out yeah
we'll figure it out somehow yeah yeah
you keep a ring on you at all times but
you must keep a ring in the damn glove
box huh
pretty much
riley mouse smiling over there rare to
see him have a feeling um
well i'm sorry the date didn't work out
uh
and we got to get more women to teach up
now how how far would it be from
marriage to
from the first date to marriage how how
how how quick are you willing to run
that gamut
uh out to anywhere between six months
and a year okay
but in six months from meeting with
somebody you you're ready to hit the
altar
if it seems right yeah if it seems right
and what size woman are you looking for
you got a height range on you
not height no um
i don't want someone that's like super
thick okay but i wouldn't be opposed
okay
so you have to you know you up to a
medium medium maybe a medium plus but
you're not looking for like a bbw or
something they say like that right some
lady that's really like in a
food contest or nothing like that right
yeah i feel you yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one
you